hello everyone I am deep I am now going
to present our recent work on clustering
permutations this is a joint work with
us and Robert
let me start with the problems that we
have uh considered in this paper so we
have studied the classical metric
committee and problem
which is a well studied problem and
which has been studied for both for
General metric as well as for many
spatial metric like euclidean having 80
check art and so on
so in this paper the metric that we have
considered is an is the Ula metric which
is a special variant of the edit metric
and also we have considered the
streaming model in this paper so
essentially if the input points arrive
in an insertion only Stream So then in
how many how much small space we can
solve this uh K median problem under
ulametric that we have studied
so let me now uh briefly motivate you
about the problem so and for the
motivation purpose I will start with k
equals to 1 so that is just the median
problem
and a slightly General variant of the
ulametric which is the edit metric
okay
so the median problem under edit metric
is also referred to as the median string
problem so let me now uh Define the
problem with respect to uh this k equals
to 1 that is median problem with under
80 distance
so in this problem we are given a set of
strings X One X two up to x n
and the objective is to find a string y
from the ambient space such that it
minimizes the median objective value so
what is the median objective value it is
the sum of distances to all the input
points
and here as I mentioned the distance we
considered is the edit distance so one
thing I want to emphasize here that the
string that we want to find
is not necessarily from the input set if
and that's why sometimes this version of
the median problem is also referred to
as the continuous median
but throughout the stock I will just use
the term medium to refer to this problem
so suppose why is there be a string that
to minimizes this median objective
function then we call Y to be abintia
so how can we now uh find this median
string because this median string
problem is a very important problem from
the Practical perspective because there
are several applications uh starting
from say computational biology DNA
storage system some specific speech
recognition classification and so on
so but unfortunately this problem is NP
hard
and if we want to find an exact solution
then the current base known algorithm
which is via dynamic programming it
takes uh time to to the end D to the N
where n is the number of input strings
where each of the input string is of
Link at most d
and it is also known that we cannot do
much better as you being strong
exponential time hypothesis
so now the
one question is uh can we do better
with approximation
so what is approximate median so just to
make sure that we all are in the same
page let me Define it formally
so suppose
op denotes the optimum objective value
so that means the objective value
obtained by this y star which is a
median string
now we call our string Y Bar a c
approximate median if and only if the
objective value attained by Y Bar
is at most c times odd
so the main question here is uh can we
get a constant Factor approximation in
polytime
so we can easily get two approximation
so why because if you recall in the
median problem I say that we want to
find a string from the ambience press
which is not necessarily from the ink
now if we just concentrate on input and
output the
one input string which attains the
minimum objective value
so then
just by using simple triangle inequality
we can show that that will achieve two
approximation
and here there is nothing specific about
any distance
so this argument holds for any imagery
so now for any distance
can I do something better for example
can we get a Peter or like can we just
uh break this two Factor
so like can we uh achieve something like
1.99 approx finish
so unfortunately so far we don't know
anything
so now
things we uh
have no idea how to get something better
than two approximation for 80 median so
one natural question is can we do
something for some special variant
and the spatial variant that we consider
is like the when the inputs are
permutations
so suppose the input strings are
permutations instead of arbitrary string
so now we can Define the distance
between two permutation in a very
similar way the edit distance is defined
so
how do we Define the distance between
two permutations
so it is defined as minimum number of
character books so character moves means
so from one permutation we take a
character and
move it to some other position
okay so for example so suppose uh here
are two permutation x one and x two
now to convert x 1 into X2
this is how we will do so let's first
take this
character 8 and
move it here
and then
take the character 2
and move it here now you can see uh just
by after moving this to character in
this fashion
we
transform this permutation X1 to X2 and
you can check later that for this
example there is no decent number of
character moves that can transform
Epsilon to x two so that's why the
distance between x one and x 2 we will
say it 2.
and this is how we get the ulam distance
so the distance that we Define just now
is a ulam distance and as I mentioned
that uh this is a facial variant of edit
distance why because if you recall what
is the edit distance so edit distance
between two strings are minimum number
of character inversion deletion of
substitution
so now in this particular case what you
can see that each of these character
move operations you can think of it as a
character deletion so basically once I
start moving something so I first delete
that character and then insert it to
some other place
okay so alternatively one can also uh
think think of this distance as D minus
LCS where T is the length of the
permutation and LCS by lcsi actually
been is the length of the LCS between
these two permutation and these are
equivalent definition
but throughout this talk I will actually
never use this uh T minus Celsius this
definition
okay so now uh when uh so just a few
slides ago I mentioned that uh we don't
know anything better for edit media and
so let's try to consider a special
variant
but is it a really a special case so the
question here is that is Ula median is
really a special case of uh edit media
so actually it is not why because since
now we are considering the set of
permutations now our objective is to
also find a permutation
that minimizes the median objective
function so now that put an extra
restriction
on the output median so previously for
edit median it could be any arbitrary
strings but now that is no longer be the
case now it has to be a formulation
so now the question is uh why should we
study uh Ula median well first of all
although it is really not a special case
of edit median but it is it captures
some of the inherent difficulties of the
uh edit median problem so maybe just uh
by uh solving
Ula median or like like providing some
good approximation algorithm maybe we
will have enough intuition uh to come up
with some better algorithm for edit
median problem or like some of the
techniques that we will
Design to get good approximation for
this Ula median we can lift it to edit
median problem
so and secondly
so it is not just a facial variant of
any median problem so actually the this
is itself is an important problem why
because power mutations can be viewed as
ranking
and ulam distance is an interestingly
similarity method
okay and this median for ranking is one
can for think it off as a thumb
aggregation of favorable rankings so how
so let me now explain with an example so
suppose uh there are fake candidates
they apply for some job and maybe there
are two open positions so we form a
hiring committee and there are several
members in the committee
and now each of this member just by
taking some interview or looking into
the profiles of these candidates they
come up with some preference order so
for example so here
the Committee Member One prefer
one and then
the second really second preference in
the preference order
the sixth candidate comes in the second
position Chief candidate comes in the
third position and so on on the other
hand say Committee Member two
rank second candidate in his uh fast
preference
and then one in the second preference
five in the third preference and so on
so now each of this Committee Member
come up with his or her own uh ranking
order
so now the question is uh how do you
proceed with this hiring decision
because these ranking orders are could
be actually potentially
conflicting
and we should not disobey any of them uh
their preference order
so that's why our objective is to
somehow come up with an aggregate rank
which
through I mean using which we can
proceed with this hiring decision and
also it should somehow capture each of
this community members preference order
and one of this aggregation uh function
that we consider is that minimizes the
sum of distances which you can see that
it is exactly the median problem but now
the inputs are just permutations or
rankings
so uh just partly for example so suppose
uh this is my aggregated rank now you
can see that from uh for each of this
input that is like whatever be the
preference order by these committee
members if you look into the first
members
order so just by
moving this character C we get this
aggregate rank for the
member 2
preference order if I just move this
character to then we get this aggregate
Rank and so on and you can see that
between
each of this uh committee members
preferred ordering and this aggregate
ranking the distance is one
and as a result
if you you can see that the sum of
distance is 4. and you can later check
that for this example you cannot uh
achieve anything later so rather like
you cannot come up with any aggregate
rank uh that achieves the sum of
distance that's strictly less than four
so now if we want to minimize the sum of
distances this is uh an aggregate rank
optimal aggregate rank
and this rank aggregation problem has
several application in Social stress
Theory Sports database statistics
internet collaborative filtering time
detection and so on
so
I have already mentioned that ulam
distance is one of the interesting to
simulated measure between bankings but
there are other dissimulating measures
as well that people have considered so
some of the other popular measures
include Kindle Tower kamini PR man foot
rule
and others
so just to uh
remark that this Kindle Tau actually
counts the number of inversions I mean
when and why I just put this as a remark
because perhaps the candle cow is the
most popular measure and also in the
next slide I will now compare our
results with uh
the rank aggregation problem under
Kindle
so
let's now focus on this one median
problem for rankings that is rank
aggregation problem with respect to two
different metric one is the perhaps the
most popular one which is the Kindle Tau
and the Ula so for Kindle Tau we already
know of a pitas
on the other hand we know that this
problem is empty heart even for 14.
but for three inputs we don't know
whether it is NP hard or
now
for coulomb distance
we don't know whether it is NP hard or
not
even for arbitrary meaning
on the other hand for
from the Upward Bound side we also don't
know much for a long time actually just
the two approximation was the base note
and only in the last year in soda 2021
we got a 2 minus Epsilon approximation
algorithm
and just a small remark that for three
inputs for ulam distance this problem is
empty
so now let me uh focus on uh the results
we got uh in our work for this one
median problem so this is so in the
beginning I mentioned that in this paper
or in this work uh we get results for
the key median problem under ulam
distance so let me now explain the
result with this special case when k
equals to 1.
so
we first show a polytime algorithm that
f is 1.99 approximation
so now you may wonder that in just in
the last slide I mentioned that
previously there was a two minus Epsilon
algorithm
so then uh how our algorithm is
different or how how our result is
different from that
so let me now put some comparison with
this previous work
so first of all the approximation Factor
now improved previously it was 2 minus
Epsilon now it is and that Epsilon was
something like 2 to the minus 40 but now
it is some decent constant it is 1.99
okay and then secondly the analysis is
now much more simpler than the previous
one
and third which is part of the most
important one is that now our algorithm
so for this one median problem can be
extended for
K median problem or arbitrary values of
K
and even with uh outliers so I am not
going to Define uh this problem with
outliers but you are welcome to look
into our paper
and the fourth thing and fourth point
that I want to emphasize is that
our algorithm for one median as well as
its extension to K median problem can be
implemented in the streaming setup with
small space how much small space that I
will comment on at the end of The Talk
so now
let me tell you uh what new we have
looked or rather how we prove our new
result
so
the new approach uh that we have taken
here is the following
so we essentially prove this uh knife
fact
that
given any number of permutations
either there is an input permutation
which is close to
an unknown medium
and as a result just by triangle
inequality
we can see that this input permutation
will achieve
good approximation say 1.99
and if that doesn't hold then
we show that there must exist and input
form rotation around which there is a
large cluster so what do I mean by large
cluster so I don't want to go into the
technical details here but just in a
informal way
so by large clustered IV that around
this input permutation there is a large
Mass
of this objective value
and for the other points
so this particular input permutation
will not perform two oars in
approximation so like for whatever we
the points around this uh input
permutation
this particular input permutation will
act as a good approximate median for
them and for the rest of the inputs it
will not
approximation and as a result when you
combine everything
and I combine all the inputs and compute
the objective value with respect to this
particular input per notation it will
attain still a good approximation like
1.99
and then the third point is that if none
of this path tool happens so then there
must exist only five input permutations
so like five good input permutations
from which we can reconstruct an
approximate media
so I want to uh emphasize this third
Point here because you should observe
that just by looking into five uh input
permutation or like performing some
algorithm over this five input
permission we get a approximate median
of the whole input ah say
and once we have uh this theorem
which I am not going to prove in this
talk so you are again welcome to read
our paper for this proof but now let me
explain I mean how we can use this
theorem to come up with a good algorithm
so the once we have this theorem
actually the algorithm is pretty
straightforward so this is what we will
do so just try all possible five tuples
from the input set and run that
reconstruction procedure and how many
possible five tuples we have since there
are n input points there are inches high
and now we add all this output to our
candidate median state so there will be
roughly into the five outputs and also
all the inputs I will add
and then finally from this candidate
median said whatever be the candidate
that attains the minimum objective value
output that
and since there are only roughly into
the five order into the five candidates
we can perform all the things in namely
in quality as long as this
reconstruction procedure
runs in polytime
okay so now assuming that reconstruction
procedure runs in polytime so now we are
in a good shape we get a quality time
algorithm and now just because of this
uh theorem that we have described in the
previous slide so one of these uh
candidate from this candidate median set
is 1.99 approximation
so now next question is how can we
extend this to K median problem so what
is K median problem
so again we are given a set of
permutations and now our objective is to
find the
top state of Atmos K permutation
and again
this subset I mean there is a set of K
permutation
okay Y and again this
State Y and need not be a subset of this
uh input swing okay
and now we want to minimize the
following objective function so for each
of the input points I will compute
its distance to the nearest neighbor in
this set y
and take the sum
so this is just an extension of the one
median problem
so instead of outputting just one input
oh I mean one uh permutation now I am
outputting the AT most K foundations
and why our algorithm can be extended
for this uh K median problem
this is just because of the following
reason so if I now
consider any arbitrary
K medium class studying so now one can
observe that our candidate median State
still contains 1.99 approximate median
for each of this cluster
because our construction was completely
oblivious to the cluster
and as a result if I just output the
best K pupil we achieve 1.99 approx
now if you run this thing naively we
will end up with consuming into the
order K running time but with the use of
clever sampling we can reduce the
running time to K login to the quantity
so now the last thing that we want to
comment on is
what about streaming
so in this streaming setup all my input
points are arrived in an insertion only
three
and now for the one median problem if I
just sample login inputs uniformly at
random then we can show that just by
performing our algorithm we can get the
same approximation
and only one point to note here is that
how do we find the best candidate
because if we cannot store all the
inputs how can we compute the objective
function well for that we can use some
of the known construction of course
and for the K median version in the
streaming setup we can do the similar
stuff so we can just build a proper core
set but now instead of uniform sampling
we have to do slightly clever sampling
and then essentially just using K Square
poly login sample
we can perform our algorithm and attains
the same approximations
so now let me conclude my talk with
mentioning some of the open problem so
first uh important open problem that I
want to highlight is that can we get a p
task for Ula media so either Formula K
median or like just for
Ula median when k equals to 1.
and then secondly
uh can we show that Ula median is
actually NP hard
which I mentioned before that part
Kindle Tau that is the case but we don't
know anything for uh under ulam distance
so can we show a similar result
and thirdly can we lift some of our
technique to this more General edit
median or for a ulam center problem
okay so now thank you and let me now
conclude my talk and I'll be looking
forward to meeting you in the conference